another week another bunch of Pokemon Go
news let's get down to it
first up Pokemon go has been updated on
iOS and Android the major part of this
update has seen the battle move damage
of all Pokemon rebalanced the Silk Road
research group on reddit has created an
exhaustive catalogue of all the damage
changes and have crowned cross chopped
the best charge move pound the rest and
have recommended that you now leverage
type advantages as all quick moves now
deal comparable damage along with the
move changes trainers can now be wreak
ustym eyes from the profile screen
allowing you to change cosmetic items
like leggings backpacks and sweat band
cap things as well as your trainers skin
tone hair and gender there have also
been improvements to gym animations and
UI among other minor changes and the
unreliable Pokemon footprints indicator
which was supposed to show you how close
you were to a particular Pokemon in the
wild has been removed entirely speaking
of tracking Pocket Monsters in the wild
the popular Pokemon tracking site
pokévision has been taken offline the
tour which allowed players to punch in
their location on an interactive map in
order to see what Pokemon were close by
went offline soon after the latest
update the services official Twitter
account tweeted on Sunday that at this
moment we are respecting Niantic and
Nintendo's wishes
this comes after comments from my antics
John Hanke last week in which he said he
was not a fan of surfaces like
pokévision and poker radar and warned
players that they might find that
services like these may not work in the
future it's worth noting that at this
stage poker radar is still up and
running as it utilizes community reports
of Pokemon locations rather than relying
on Pokemon gos API confirmed features
still to come to the game include a
global leaderboard ways to customize
gyms and a trading feature what do you
think about the latest updates to
Pokemon go do you think the third-party
tools like pokévision constitute
cheating as your vaporeon finally been
defeated in the gym its add in at last
weeks let us know in the comments and
for the latest on Pokemon go keep polka
stopping by GameSpot